russian forces are pressing in closer to
ukraine's capital kiev on day two of a
full-scale invasion the mayor says the
city has entered a defensive phase and
ukrainian military vehicles are entering
the capital to protect it from
approaching russian troops
air raid sirens have been sounding in
kiev and other cities prompting people
to take shelter in metro stations there
have been reports of clashes in and
around kiev after russia bombarded the
city with missiles overnight ukraine's
government says at least 137 of its
soldiers and civilians have been killed
across the country russian president
vladimir putin has claimed he's willing
to negotiate after ukraine's president
zielinski raised the possibility of
discussing neutral status for his
country but the conditions for such
talks are not immediately clear
let's join dw correspondent nick
connolly on the line he was in kiev and
like so many others has been forced to
flee welcome nick can you tell us where
you are and what's going on
so we've just been heading south west
from here trying to
keep away from fighting given the kind
of unclear um pattern of fighting in the
geography and the kind of possibility of
trying to predict where things can
happen we basically just chose uh the
direction that seemed to be the least
likely to see fighting so we're heading
um towards to do vinegar which is kind
of poorly towards um
poland and the eu um but even there
we've seen lots of tanks ukrainian tanks
heading towards kiev to join that fight
there we've seen russian planes in the
sky above us
lots of people on the roads um big lines
outside petrol stations people trying to
reach all their cars um and checkpoints
going up you really can kind of see the
kind of sandbags being uh piled up each
other and this is all really in flux you
can tell the kind of local security
services really are just in the first
hours of this trying to kind of get a
grip on where the funds are going to be
where the fight is going to come from
and what's going to be expected of them
and people who stayed in the capital are
they just hoping for the best or
preparing for an actual invasion
i think that is no longer
an impossibility i mean lots of people
have tried divine now have maybe stayed
in here but moved from the city centre
to
suburbs to maybe their uh weekend houses
somewhere
anywhere away from obvious targets like
government buildings or military
installations that's actually a big fear
that
russia will try and target the basically
the kind of uh
central central can your arousal point
to the ukraine administration places
where the effort being planned from so
even office buildings not necessarily
barracks might be targeted people trying
to move away as possible
and then again they face another night
in bomb shelters or in metro stations
like they had like yesterday already um
it was kind of
obviously terrifying hearing those
sirens for the first time not being able
to tell where that shooting is coming
from where those missiles are coming
from um we've seen extensive damage to
uh to rhythm
in kiev yesterday um as a result of uh
as we have found it
missiles
so it's definitely a very fast moving
situation one which i guess all the
weeks of this was building up i don't
think anyone would expect to be finding
themselves
and president zelinski is still in the
country how dangerous is the situation
for him
well he said that he believes that he is
target number one that the goal of this
russian offensive is to
presumably to
take his life to order to take him
prisoner
and then
the kind of playbook would be
presumed russia to then install its own
uh kind of pocket leadership its own uh
man its own favorites to
lead ukraine and to then agree some kind
of deal that ukraine permanently bound
to russia and
not just not in nato and not neutral but
also far closer in terms of its
relationship to russia to say belarus
right now than to other former soviet
countries so that's a real worry very
aggressive rhetoric coming out of moscow
as they began this uh this uh onset this
intervention talking about
demilitarizing and denazifying
ukraine as part of their strategy to
kind of delegitimize ukraine and say
it's some kind of neo-nazi state um
without you know even bothering to
actually explain how they see that why
they would explain that it's just the
kind of uh claim that's thrown out there
to try and uh yeah
create some kind of justification for
this presumably largely back home in
russia where lots of people are now
going out on the streets and asking why
their government is doing this this
claims that ukraine is a brotherly
neighbor country why is russia bombing
its closest neighbor without
making the case which it seems why this
is not happening
and nick lots of people are leaving not
just the cities but the country as well
uh what are the main routes out
well for now the main route is opponents
straight west out of kiev towards leve
which is the biggest city on the polish
border but there have been issues today
that along some of the main roads
leading west there was fighting we
understand there's fighting between
russian forces potentially in russian
tanks and ukrainian army just within
about 15 kilometers of that main artery
leading out and given the numbers of
people out and about they were very very
long traffic jams people stuck for hours
in time so you can imagine the anxiety
of being stuck in traffic it's basically
parked on the motorway knowing that
shooting and
even tank fire is happening within a
massive kilometer where you are not
being able to move it's a very difficult
situation it sent lots of people trying
to travel further away from that
fighting further south in terrain that's
often pretty difficult with
pothole roads going you know endlessly
uh between villages but we've just been
you know spending last few hours
basically just uh at about 50 kilometers
an hour between villages which is
endless endless
lines of vehicles um all trying to find
a way out so now people aren't losing
their calm i've been pretty struck by
the fact that given how difficult it is
even to find fuel uh let alone know
where to go and how to get there
i haven't seen people panic or rape
their voices or push ahead in queues at
the petrol station so for all the kind
of
severity and the kind of importance of
the situation people are
in some way
keeping calm and
dealing with the situation as best they
can
nick uh thank you so much for letting us
know what's going on do try and stay
safe thank you for now nick connolly in
kiev and just outside kiev i should say
well the situation on the ground is of
course changing rapidly and it's
difficult to confirm so let's get more
from dw reporter william bluecroft on
what we've been able to broadly piece
together today thanks very much it is
indeed very complicated
uh there's of course been air attacks
all around the country and major cities
all around the country but there's want
to focus on the land
war that is happening right now in major
places
all around the country first let's have
the general map of ukraine you know
ukraine between poland belarus and
russia and over to the east
the separatist held part of ukraine
that's been that way since 2014.
there are some key points here let's get
a closer look now where russian land
forces are coming in from we see them
first coming in from the north
through russia's ally belarus
the east
from russian bases russia proper itself
pushing in through that russian-backed
separatist zone in the donbus region and
of course in the south here we have
crimea crimea is a ukrainian peninsula
that russia in 2014 illegally annexed
there's been a naval base there for
quite a long time and russia is using
that as a point to go into points
further south now what exactly is
happening in these areas let's have a
quick look
first of all of course the all eyes are
on kiev the capital of ukraine the big
prize for russia
they're moving in from the north we can
see from the map how close kiev is to
belarus it's not a long drive for
russian forces to get there we've been
hearing that there's fighting at least
in the northern part of the city
possibly moving into the city right now
and the defense ministry the ukrainian
defense ministry has said that they want
civilians there to stay indoors and
prepare molotov cocktails for possibly
fighting
uh fighting those russian forces as they
come in if the ukrainian military is not
strong enough to do it on their own now
of course then we have the east this is
where most ukrainian forces are because
they've been fighting this insurgency
this rebel
area they've been fighting that since
2014 so that's where most ukrainian
forces are and that's where we see in at
least three different major points
russian forces coming in from the east
and also from the south from crimea as i
said that were that russian naval bases
and we've been seeing amphibious
landings reports of that from mariopol
and even odessa key strategic locations
on ukraine's black sea coast now one
possibility here one of the biggest
fears is
if the troops in the south and the east
can link up they may be able to cut off
the ukrainian forces in the east get
them trapped there so they wouldn't be
able to help in the fight in points
further west such as the capital
this is the very perilous situation that
ukraine is facing right now of course
ukraine outmatched uh an out gunned but
there's a lot we don't know
how long ukraine can withstand uh
russian attacks of course how much
russia is willing to commit to this
fight and what exactly russia's end
goals are whether it's simply to give
that separatist region over to the
separatists in fully as more so than in
2014
if they're looking to split the country
entirely between east and west and of
course if they want to do complete
regime change and occupy the country
entirely it's very very difficult to say
very difficult to say where the losses
are right now and of course very
perilous in the days ahead all right uh
william gluecroft thank you so much for
that
all right now let's get a view of this
conflict from one of ukraine's
neighbours uh thomas hendrick ilves was
the president of estonia from 2006 to
2016.
welcome to dw
how much of what's happening in ukraine
today is because western governments
underestimated vladimir putin
well western is uh
depends which western government first
of all let me just start off by saying
that the distance between kiev and
italian estonia
350 kilometers is exactly the same
distance as
berlin to kiev so neighbors we're both
neighbors
um but certainly uh i would say for a
good
20 years uh
the western part of nato and the
european union
uh did not take
that that seriously the eastern
countries
warnings and concerns about the behavior
of the russians because of course their
rhetoric as well as their behavior
was starkly different
right so um some eu countries including
your own have dead have today decided to
send more weapons to support ukraine
what sort of impact do you think this
will have
well
it's very difficult to say what the
actual weapons what kind of impact they
will will have but certainly it stands
in stark contrast to the decision by
some other governments to not do
anything
or send any weapons
and so uh which there are several so uh
i mean i think it certainly uh
provides moral support to the ukrainians
who otherwise feel quite abandoned all
right let's talk about um
germany's decision then to refuse to
send weapons and indeed to stop other
countries from sending german weapons do
you regard that as being a mistake
quite and i find even more bizarre is
the rationale that was used for a number
of
policies
but let's face it ukraine was
along with poland and belarus a far
greater
victim of
of german
aggression and during world war ii
in terms of numbers killed in the
absolute numbers as well as in
proportion of the population
than was russia
so
it does strike people who know their
the history of the bloodlands as uh
timothy snyder called them to be a
somewhat odd decision
looking at from the the german point of
view
the
logic there is that having
seen and witnessed and perpetrated those
horrors in the past they are very
reluctant to go down uh to go anywhere
near that path again
well when you read the president the
bundes president uh
say justify nordstream 2
by saying that germany has a special
debt
to
russia
and therefore must do north stream 2
and
it's ukraine that is against it among
other interalia and also poland it just
it it does not really wash except that
we're in the situation now where where
germany has uh uh put a stop to to north
stream too so the the company the
country is very much um getting in in
line with uh its allies i wonder
how worried you are uh there in estonia
about a spillover from this current
conflict
well why should we have more of a
spillover than anyone else i mean i
think there's a general spillover that
europe should worry about
um
but other than that i think
i mean
we are not uh we're not direct neighbors
uh but uh
but certainly uh if russia is successful
i think it will encourage even more
aggressive behavior
will stand this term president putin has
suggested negotiations in minsk
can there still be talks with uh mr
putin after what has happened
well that's the decision for president
zielinski to make quite clearly not uh
but i would find it extremely difficult
uh especially since belarus is an ally
of the belligerent
but you know thucydides said that uh the
strong do what they want and the uh the
weak do what they must
so uh we'll see i don't i don't really
imagine him doing that given current the
current situation but on the other hand
i don't have as adequate uh an overview
of how bad it is
i do not think it would find broad
support in the ukrainian public though
which i think is
quite uh quite fiercely opposed to
to caving into moscow and its rather
ridiculous
demands all right thank you for joining
us uh thomas hendrick ilvest former
president of estonia
now if you're just joining us you might
be wondering how relations between a
former soviet bloc members deteriorated
so quickly dw reporter michelle stockman
has taken a look at how ukraine's west
would push including its desire to join
the north atlantic military alliance has
nato has so incensed russia
eight years ago vladimir putin had a
friend in kiev president viktor
yanukovych
having pro-russia president
was very important for russia it meant
that a lot of reforms would be stalled
it meant that any union with the west
would not be possible
and in 2013 when yanukovych refused to
sign an association agreement for closer
ties to the eu
the people
rebelled
scores died hundreds were injured in the
maidan revolution
yanukovych was ousted and a new pro-eu
government formed
the kremlin answered back
with tanks
and annexed ukraine's crimean peninsula
moscow also threw its support behind
separatists in the pro-russia donbass
region
war broke out as the two eastern
provinces donetsk and luansk declared
independence
european leaders brought the two sides
together for the mints peace accords
but the war ground to a stalemate
a development far from the battlefield
also spiked tensions
in june 2015 russia announced the
nordstrom 2 gas pipeline
its route under the baltic sea would
bypass ukraine meaning kiev would lose
billions in transit fees
another turning point in 2019 with
vladimir zelinski as ukraine's president
he vowed to restore the donbass region
and renewed calls for nato membership
many leaders hints likely that ukraine
shouldn't take the risk of talking
constantly about membership of the
alliance
because this risk is connected to
russia's reaction
but that was a red line for moscow
no one thought that if ukraine creates
such threats for russia
he creates similar threats for herself
it was one of putin's justifications for
the russian troop build-up around
ukraine's borders
but unlike eight years ago ukraine is a
battle-hardened nation that's vowed to
resist
so let me recap the latest developments
for you russian forces are closing in on
ukraine's capital kiev on day two of a
full-scale invasion the mayor says the
city's entered the defensive phase and
ukrainian military vehicles are entering
the capital to protect it from
approaching troops
sirens have been sounding in kiev and
other cities prompting people to take
shelter in metro stations they've also
been reports of clashes in and around
the city after russia bombarded it with
missiles overnight ukraine's government
says at least 137 of its soldiers and
civilians have been killed across the
country russian president vladimir putin
claims he's willing to negotiate after
ukraine's vladimir zelinski raised the
possibility of neutral status for
ukraine but the conditions for such
talks are not immediately clear
one of vladimir putin stated reasons for
invading ukraine is the danger of the
nato military alliance coming too close
to russian territory now with war on its
doorstep leaders from the alliance are
holding a virtual summit to discuss
increasing its presence on its eastern
border
nato comprises 30 countries with the us
the most powerful if you take a closer
look at its european borders we see the
baltic states of estonia and latvia both
border russia while lithuania borders
russia's ally belarus
troop deployments in estonia and latvia
are small at just over 1 000 each while
reinforcements from germany recently
landed in lithuania poland has just over
6 000 troops at the moment and the
member states on the south eastern flank
have smaller garrisons the us is sending
reinforcements as the alliance moves to
strengthen its eastern edges
well a short while ago and nato
secretary general jens stoltenberg gave
his opening remarks ahead of the virtual
summit
russia has shattered peace on the
european continent
what we have warned against for months
has come to pass
despite all our efforts to find a
diplomatic solution
moscow bears
sole responsibility for the
deliberate cold-blooded and long-planned
invasion
we condemn
russia's aggressions in the strongest
possible terms
and call on russia to immediately
sees its military action
we stand with the brave people of
ukraine we fully support ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
it's right of self-defense and its right
to choose his own path
unless the russian ministry besieged the
ukrainian capital moscow has said it
will topple the ukrainian government the
mayor of kiev has announced that the has
announced that the defense of the city
has begun thousands of civilians have
fled those who remain are braced for a
violent confrontation
another terrifying start to the day in
kiev
overnight there was more destruction
bombs rained down forcing residents to
flee to safety in bunkers
metro stations and cellars
packed with residents grappling to come
to terms with their new reality
it's hard but i'm holding on
a nearby house caught fire and there
were many victims
and we were waiting until seven o'clock
in the morning in our apartment in the
car door in the bathroom until the end
of curfew so that we could come here i
work here
i feel mostly tired and anxious
it's so strange
above them soldiers on the streets of
central kiev and reports of gunfire near
the government district
and on the edge of the capital an enemy
aircraft the ukrainian army claims they
shot down
meanwhile ukraine's president sent a
message to russia
russia will have to talk to us sooner or
later
talk about how to end the fighting and
stop this invasion
the sooner the conversation begins the
fewer losses there will be for russia
itself
but in moscow repeated unfounded claims
from the kremlin suggests there's no end
to russia's invasion in sight
the aim of the operation was openly
declared demilitarization and
de-nazification
we want the ukrainian people or as
president putin said all the people
living in modern ukraine to have the
opportunity to freely determine their
future destiny
but for most ukrainians the only future
they're contemplating now is whether to
remain in their homeland or to flee
european union leaders have agreed new
sanctions on russia over its invasion of
ukraine but they held back from cutting
it off from the global swift payment
system
following resistance from countries
including germany european commission
president ursula fonda lyon says the
measures agreed or would have a major
impact on the russian economy
we will hold the kremlin accountable
the package of massive and targeted
sanctions
european leaders approved tonight
clearly demonstrates that
it will have maximum impact on the
russian economy and the political elite
and it is built of five pillars the
first at the financial sector
second the energy sector the third is
the transport sector
fourth are export controls and the ban
of export financing and finally
visa policy
well let's hear now from svetlana
tikanovskaya she's the leader of the
opposition in belarus which borders
ukraine um which has been
a bella rate excuse me belarus which has
been allied with russia in its assault
she was forced into exile by the
country's autocratic leader alexander
lukashenko and welcome to dw can we
start with your reaction to the events
of the last couple of days
you know yesterday in the morning of
course we woke up in new reality
we didn't expect this war
would happen we didn't believe in this
and
but we see that illegitimate regime made
belarus the country aggressor
uh putin partnered with lukashenka and
attacked ukraine and this is the price
the lukashenko is paying for kremlin
support in 2020 which allowed uh
lukashanka to stay in power
uh so i really want to express
solidarity with all ukrainians pearson
people don't want to fight especially
they don't want to fight against ukraine
our
neighbor people we laugh and we want to
be friends of course with them
it's hard i mean what do you base that
on because we here in the west we hear
the narrative that is coming out of the
kremlin we hear the narrative from the
kremlin talking about denatification uh
talking about a genocide against russian
people this is the same story that
russians are hearing so if that's what
they're hearing
what makes you so sure they don't want a
war
you know our people in the 21st century
have to
have to realize the situation by
themselves and not to follow propaganda
messages because peop people in any
country can decide their future for
themselves and they want to use their
language they want to live peacefully in
their countries and
look i'm communicating with you
ukrainians
nobody complained that you know
ukrainian government abusing them or
whatever
and of course this uh this narrative
this message is sent by uh russia uh
doesn't have anything to
you know nothing
that
nothing real
and part of russia's attack has been
launched from military bases uh in your
country belarus um did is vladimir putin
in complete control of the country
we see that
illegitimate regime can't control a
situation anymore uh lukashanka lost his
legitimacy in 2020 and now he is selling
our country to
to
kremlin
he's
like a huge uh aircraft career for
russia and bruce provides is its
territory infrastructure military
facilities to russia and the belarusian
air defense system is serving to russian
missile and fight attack
and i know that you've called on members
of uh but the belarus military not to
participate in russia's war what sort of
response have you had
you know i know that uh majority of
bills and people don't support uh this
war don't support the participation of
uh
the russian army in in this war only 12
percent uh believe that belarus and must
uh bloss must send its sold soldiers and
only 13 in support of a russian campaign
56 percent believe belarus must stay in
neutral and i hope
that people in the minklatura and in
army understand this as well and they
will not
fulfill
criminal orders of the regime right
there was a lot of criticism of western
governments for not supporting you
enough and the opposition enough when
the regime in belarus cracked down
on the pro-democracy movement that you
lead
there's a lot of the same criticism now
when it comes to supporting ukraine did
i wonder how you feel it is the west
failing uh eastern europe
you know actually um i'm grateful for to
european union for united position about
belarus and i saw a lot of sympathy and
solidarity uh with belarusian people but
actually the first strong package of
sanctions have been imposed in 10 months
after crackdown of
of belarus and uprising and of course
it's too late
and i think that uh half measures only
harm in this situation and i'm sure that
much more could be done towards uh
belarusian regime and much more can be
done now uh to support ukraine well and
just on that with so much of the the
world's attention now focused on on
ukraine i wonder do do you worry that
belarus's fight for democracy will get
forgotten
uh fight for the for democracy will
never be forgotten and moreover uh as
belarus um
is a part of this aggression of course
it will be interconnected with this
crisis in ukraine and moreover
while all the attention is on this
ukrainian russian crisis uh very
important um events are going on in
belarus you know that
this sunday we are going to have
so-called referendum launched by
illegitimate regime and what is very
concerned about this referendum uh that
ukashanka is going to amend our
constitution and the paragraph about
neutrality and non-nuclear status of
our country uh is deleted so it be
belarusian became a threat for european
security because you know kashanka is
unpredictable and next day after this
so-called constitution is adopted
nuclear weapon russian nuclear weapon
can be on the territory of uh belarus
it's a sobering thought thank you so
much for joining us belarusian
opposition leader svetlana tikanovskaya
thank you